[Music]
Runk hey guys it is me Chris deia and I
will be in Sacramento January 13th for
two shows at the Crest theater Brea
Improv I will be there uh January 18th
Phoenix January 20th then some shows in
elpac El Paso uh Albuquerque Colona BC
Vancouver BC uh two shows in Vancouver
BC who sold out the first one uh in
February and then March 1 we got
Rochester and kitner Ontario sheveport
Louisiana and March 15th we got Houston
and Corpus chrisan Durham and norfol we
got a bunch of them go to chris.com to
get tickets and um also you can go to my
while you're there at my website go get
the uh the new special grow or die go
get that and stream it and watch it
download it whatever you want appreciate
it self uh made and all that
self-distributed we love you guys and uh
other than that here come the next
episode of
[Music]
congratulations yo uh it is what is it
it is the day after Christmas I did not
release a thing on on Christmas or uh I
did not record on Christmas is when I
usually record on the Mondays and then
it's Tuesday now I'm recording so this
will be a day later you guys will
probably be for a day you guys will be
like what happened what's going on I
can't even believe what's going on in
the in the congratulations Community but
we are all good and we are we are here
and we're just going to be a day late
maybe I'll maybe I'll put out a video
before this uh let people know it'll be
a day late but whatever um sorry about
that you know your boy took the day off
suum he took the day off he didn't want
to do recording on on uh on uh on
Christmas and he also didn't even want
to do recording before that because he
was in Arizona spending it with his
in-laws hey what the heck so Su him
um but yeah he uh I went to uh Arizona
and I then went to uh here to have
Christmas with the family and is a
beautiful thing um Christmas was great
hopefully you picked up some merch here
the uh grow or die t-shirt with the
sword on it look at that man it's nice
too I work out and it sometimes it looks
real good my muscles get all beefy up
into it and starts looking the back is
cool it's like that you know it's like
that what is
it metal kind of look but I it says grow
or die anyway chris.com I I I I uh I
have this and then somebody said great
another guy who doesn't even listen to
metal using the metal font so I don't
even I didn't even know it was metal
font honestly until the guy said that so
I just like the font what can I say dude
I'm subconsciously metal you know what
I'm
saying subconsciously death metal dude
um I'm too dry how about that y'all too
dry is is that just what's up when am I
when am I not going to be dry in my
night right nostril and my throat when
does it happen God because if it does
just let me know when so I could write
it out and be like well I I can have
like an advent calendar for my dryness
be like oh we got six you know even if
it's six more six more years of dryness
whatever it is dude I I'm so
dry I can't even believe it my nose is
constantly bleeding yes and my throat
constantly feels like I has Cott in it
yes dude he's dry as
[__] so I wake up and I have to and I
and I you know I better I'll tell you
what dude I better have water on my
night table I better have that I better
have had the uh
foresight to put not just one but two
bottles of water on my night table cuz
guess what your boy's going to Johnny
wakes up at 5:30 a.m. I'm I'm going to
wake up at 5:30 a.m. and I'm going to be
it's like I'm going to have a throat
full of cotton
balls and a right nostril full
of capillaries just bursting at the
seams so I wake up bloody nose can't
talk and and let's just hope that I have
a at least two bottles of water because
if I do I could gulp it down and maybe I
can get back to sleep maybe just maybe
but if I don't he's got to get up
he's got to get up and it's not it's not
just bad because he's got to get up to
get water he's got to get up to I can
get up to do one thing and go back to
sleep if I get up to do two things
forget it if I would get up and I got to
go pee and get
water that's it I'm up I'm reaching the
age where if I wake up too
early and have to do something okay if I
have to do two things forget it and and
by the way could be the most minuscule
things of all time I could do one thing
I can go I can go
potty but if I go potty come back look
at my phone even for a split second and
then get back in bed I'm done dude I'm
toast I'm busted and dusted
dude I'm roasted and
toasted and I just can't so uh I don't
look at my phone I get up I go potty God
I hate waking up to go pee pee I really
hate waking up to go peee I God I hate
it so much and I'm dry so it's all good
anyway how I dry but also have to why
don't I just use why doesn't my body
just use the
pp to De to hydrate myself doesn't work
like that right we got to redo bodies um
but yeah so look so last Monday did an
episode of
congratulations and went to sleep woke
up and I had a fever I don't know what
the I was sick but I was not really sick
it didn't feel all that bad I was in bed
for a day I was in bed for a full day
wow that day it feels
like it's so weird I actually did stay
in bed all day which I never do that
never do that I got out of bed at 6:00
p.m. and then the next day I was kind of
and then we left to go to my in-laws and
I felt kind of better but still was like
you know when you get that sick where
you're like it's sick for like however
many days the nucleus of it is and
then it it hangs on and so it hung on
uh and then it like morphed into just
like a stomach thing forget it and I
don't like to be gross you know I don't
like to be gross I don't like that kind
of style of Comedy or whatever but oh my
god
dude I mean my number twos were
Bonkers my number two dude I would sit
down on the toilet and my butthole would
go like
this let's get into
it it was like a it was honestly like a
meth like a death metal
band that's how it came
out and then I'd get it I'd be like I
guess that's it did you ever go number
two so hard and that you're so and it's
so diarrhea and I don't you know I'm not
saying this was me it was but I'm saying
generally when you go diarrhea and it
comes out and
dude you're it's coming out so liquidy
and so I don't want to be
gross and you can't stop it and it's
just you're that you're so
delirious that you're just like oh my
god dude oh God you just start thinking
of things like I gotta go to church I
got to start going to church not you're
not even in a religious way you're just
like I need more things to do I got a
church and go I got a
hike and I got a church and hike and I
should really wear more green Kristen
likes it and it
was and dude you get up and I'd be I'd
get up and I'd I'd walk back
out I'd take about a few you know steps
and I go like this my my my bog like
this we are
unfinished I mean I have the moon walk
back to the bathroom cuz I couldn't
afford time turning back around it was
unbelievable two days what got better
okay got better your boy got cocky all
right now what's that mean had a full
Christmas dinner and then had another
Christmas dinner had a Christmas dinner
fully at 5:30 and then I go like this
damn I'm hungry and chrisy says don't
make a don't make don't order food I
just make you a plate she made me a
plate dude hey nothing's Doper than when
your girl makes you a plate so I go all
right howed it then guess what oh let's
just check the freezer let's just check
it huge tub of chocolate ice cream let's
just eat some of it ate all of it well
left a few
bites went
upstairs
dude out my I'm talking about dude oh
we're back you know what I'm talking
about like fully back in
business with the number
two do I have that it go like this oh
dude oh you thought that was
it come on and it's not
working sound plan ain't working all
good boy this app really doesn't work a
lot that's great I'll play it again
um so uh yeah dude my my my tummy was
like run it back dude run it back and
and then that's fine
dude and the toilet on the on the on the
in the you know
porcelain I don't want to be gross but
I'm gross whatever I talk about life
this is the
life um um straight up told by the way
last time in
Oxnard uh did a 17 I told a story about
going number
two and I was like dude I'm just going
to do this I don't know if it's funny or
not dude it was a full 17 minute story
about me going number two 17
minutes and it was awesome I might have
included my but oh had a 17 minute of
going
like that's what I wanted to
do hey I'm done I'm done I'm going to go
number two oops never
mind um
so Christmas was great Calvin got a
bounce house uh Santa brought him a
bounce house which is awesome Santa it
was great Santa did that and
um I when your kid turns like three and
a half and then you have another kid
which is what happened with me I we had
uh we had we had Calvin three and a half
uh two three years later we had Billy
and Billy is now eight months and Calvin
is almost four and Calvin is at the
point where K loves opening presents
when he gets his presents it's game on
and then what happens Billy opens a
present and it's like the most
rudimentary it's like put it in a block
on a block that's a present for infant
toys are [__] by the way they're so
that's such a
racket they'll just be like yeah put it
together it doesn't matter what it is
put a box on it and then and then a
balloon shape and then a star and
something with a string on it that they
can pull it about an inch and that's a
toy and it cost like you know $20 and
you just buy it and your infant will
just you know just smack it and I guess
that's the point he's not turning the
key in it like there's a key in it and
I'm like I know you're eight months but
turn the key in it doesn't start
anything but at least and he doesn't
turn the keys
just and it's a box with like a a string
and a key and then a like a a a triang
angle in it that you can press a little
bit and then two of those popper
things
and and and and so like I'll get this
for Billy and he'll un you know we'll
unwrap it to it honestly you shouldn't
do Christmas for an infant I just
realized you should just do Christmas
starting at three two Even Calvin last
year I mean I guess it was nice but he
didn't really know what was going on now
he gets
it but like dude we get we got Billy a
few presents and and he open him and
he's smacking him around and then
Calvin's like looking at he's with his
presents and he go over to Billy's like
he wants Billy's presents he's like I I
want that and Billy starts crying like
hey buddy got a share come on buddy you
got a share and he's like I want that
one I'll give him this and then gives
him like a
shoe here he'll play with this give him
my shoe and I gotta leave I'm like where
my shoes and he's like bil's playing
with it you can't leave bil he playing
with it um so anyway dude um Christmas
was good though had the whole family
over Dad Mom Aunt Uncle
cousins
um and uh it was good
man Christmas is uh my favorite holiday
and it was the first Christmas that I've
been with my family that was normal in
probably 3 years cuz of covid and then I
was in rehab and then
um it's weird though I think giving
gifts here you know what I'm going to
say dude here it is God I never thought
I'd say this I'm a [__] for saying this
and I remember when I was a kid thinking
nah never be
me giving gifts is just as good as
receiving gifts [__]
dude I'm
selfless
[__] [__] man he wanted to be selfish
but your boy done [__] grown up I'm
pissed of about it do you understand the
joy I got from getting gifts
[__] and now I like giving them just as
much oh godamn it dude I hate that about
me it sucks man and guess why it sucks
because it's
awesome man I remember when I came down
to this thing and Santa brought the
Masters of the Universe castle of gry
skull nothing was better than that
nothing when I came down and I got that
board game Crossfire
Crossfire dude when I came down and I
got the laser tag
[__] nothing was
better
nothing until I got my son air rocket
launchers he opened them up and he
played with them all day and he had fun
and guess what dude I had
fun oh [__] your boy done grown up and I
didn't want to and I don't I want to go
back by the
way I
know what is it about that I want to
have that first fun again but I can't
like nobody somebody gave me Castle
Grace call right now for He-Man you know
I open it up it wouldn't be fun maybe
I'll have a little bit of nostalgia be
like oh I remember this oh [__] yeah
look at Battle cat the way he goes in in
there there's a jawbridge but dude I'd
rather give my son a bounce house I'd
rather give my other infant child a
little you know I guess they'd have to
be three because my infant child doesn't
appreciate the [__] you know and that's
no fault to his own but
like [__] I like giving just as much as
receiving not when it comes to sex
though and that's why I have an intimacy
problem so there we go there we go there
we
go really got to figure that one
out I'm on it
2024 New Year's resolutions you got New
Year's resolutions like a jackass you
got a New Year's resolution like a
jackass that's going to fail don't even
have one do it
now this probably doesn't come out until
no this will come out yeah before New
Year's do it now
dude wow I ate so bad over the break
though and because I was sick and I was
with my in-laws and I was going to work
outside and it was raining in Phoenix I
didn't work out for [__] 10 days
dude what I went today you know just
move the bones a little bit as
Christopher Lloyd said when I shot a
movie with him way back in 1999 I saw
him in the hotel gym I said hey what are
you doing here he said moving the bones
keeping the bones
moving think about it all the time dude
so
um yeah
dude I I can't believe I like giving
gifts that sucks dude
I'm I'm I betrayed myself I'm a [__] I
never thought when I was a kid I used to
think like I people say giving is like
receiving it's just as good and I go as
a kid I go like this n that'll never be
me no no no no no no no I figured out
life and I did by the way when I was
nobody knew more than anything than me
when I was eight and then you grow up as
you grow up you learn how you [__]
start not knowing more [__] you know
everything when you're [__] 15 you
know everything and then after that it's
like you start figuring out a little bit
too much and you start not knowing stuff
it sucks it's like the more you know the
less you
know if we could just stay that age dude
and just be the smartest you know how
much how if dude if if we just grow to
be 15 years old do you know how far
society would be be like that Meme with
the futuristic stuff and the cars would
be flying we would be living to be 150
even though we would be living to be 15
we there would be no cancer HIV there'
be no nothing C ID would be a thing of
the
past people wouldn't even be having sex
anymore they'd be doing that thing that
they did in De Demolition Man where they
put the glasses on and they just go H H
and they sit next to each other and they
have orgasms but they don't even have to
copulate ahh there' be nobody in the
world anymore because you just be you
know what I'm saying doing it with your
by yourselves but it seemed like you're
actually having intercourse but you're
not but you're just sitting there in
those
pods oh and dude pretty soon the
population will be under
control cuz everybody's having so many
kids you know even
me
um turned on jingle all the way I think
jingle all the way is my favorite
Christmas movie The turber
Man although I do like
uh I tried to put on another one A
Christmas Story or a
Christmas you'll shoot your eye out you
know Kristen never saw that I tried to
watch it and
then I don't want to honestly watch
anything anymore man what about that
thanks Tik
Tok I don't want to watch anything more
thanks
reals I don't want to watch anything
more thanks people who don't use the
Millennium Gap thanks the millennial Gap
thanks guys the right the
millennial whatever the hell it's called
how Millennial start videos when they're
like
this hi I you know they don't they
[__] swipe out dude you got to start
in the middle of a
word of what I was talking about that's
how a video would talk what did I miss
pretty soon videos are going to be after
the
video it's just going to have be some
guy's going to be like the end and
you're going be like that was awesome
content
um I just don't know anymore we all got
to be more like this how about this
Swiss City consider ERS legalizing
cocaine for recreational use in pilot
program
uh they say War on Drugs has failed
quote how
how um that's not the way to do it you
know I mean look if you're going to
legalize cocaine legalize
cocaine but not because the war has
failed you [__] you know or at least
don't say that I guess they could tax it
now at least right do they even have
taxes over there who knows but
like that's like being like oh yo dude
there's too many serial killers just
it's fine if you kill more than two
people it's legal just you can't just
kill two it's too hard there's too
many let's just make sure we tax axes
and and and
Ryon the capital of Switzerland is
considering launching a pilot program to
test the legal sale of cocaine how
hilarious you know what I bet that
people I mean besides the real addicts
the allore of doing it would go
away you know what I'm
saying like my wife doesn't care if I
eat sweets but like if she went to bed
and she was like remember now don't eat
any sweets guess who's eating
sweets guess he's not telling
her I don't even give a [__] if I just
have a Lifesavers they're all mine
God what [__] ass eats
Lifesavers right and not the minty kind
minty kind mint okay I get it you need a
mint bro fruit
Lifesavers what kind of [__] [__]
candy is that do they even around
anymore they yeah they have to be
Lifesavers dude the
[__] the balls to call them
Lifesavers
dude that's some 19 what 50 oh cuz
they're the shape of
Lifesavers okay I guess it's
fine but but the reason why they did it
because of the do on Tandra you know it
so we can still be
mad I just don't know you ever dude I
haven't eaten
candy I haven't eaten candy in so long I
ate Candy the other day after after was
after Halloween where I had some laying
down I'm not talking about chocolate
dude I'm talking about like smarty sweet
ret tards sour gummy and I go like this
I'm like man I haven't had one of these
in years what did I say it was like a
sour something you know what it was a
sour burger like the I don't know why
they make everything it's it was like
this big and it was like a gummy sour
gummy burger like too many foods
involved and it was too confusing I'm
like I'mma eat this I bet I hate it I
ate it dude guess what I did after that
ate four more sour gummy Burgers bro you
haven't had candy in a while eat some
candy it'll blow your [__] mind my
buddy when I was younger he used to say
uh yo I don't e anything they make in a
lab and I was like all right man and it
kind of stuck with me guess what though
dude now I eat stuff that they make in
the lab that candy was so good and I ate
it dude and I ate Smarties and I ate
sour gummy Burgers oh [__]
man it was good candy is so good and it
sucks it sucks that it's so good cuz
it's so bad for you but that's nature
[__] doing its thing ain't it I used
to think why is Yo here's what it means
to grow up I used to think why is the
good food for your bad if the bad if why
is the good why is the bad food for you
tastes good if it does bad things to you
wouldn't
biologically an evolutionary wouldn't us
as we
evolve grow to like the stuff that's
good for us more than the stuff that's
bad for us wouldn't we I mean we we've
been alive for so many thousands of
hundreds of millions of years whatever I
don't know how long but I mean there it
wasn't just me Our Generation there was
our parents and then our grandparents
and our grandparents grandparents and
our grandparents grandparents
grandparents you could do it to where
you said grandparents so many different
times and
then all of those like all of our
grandparents grandparents grandparents
grandparents they all couldn't bi
biologically and evolutionarily figure
it out to where re's peanut butter cups
was the new salad
and I go
that's so now I'm like well how can I
believe in science and then I go like
this oh it's not just
us that's Nature's Way what about the
Earth they don't want us here we're
[__] the Earth up so it's the Earth's
fault that sugar is bad for you and
earth makes us feel like it tastes good
yo sometimes he's so deep deep deep in
the [__] Vortex of the truth that it
is just
unreal Sugar's good because we're bad
for the Earth and the Earth needs us to
get cancer so the Earth can still be the
Earth as long as it needs to be
sometimes he's so deep in the vortex of
truth that people just all turn into the
weebay meme like
this oh that deah boy he's got a real
say what you want about me but do not
say I'm not in the vortex of Truth deep
deep on the seven layer dip of I mean I
am in the
beans of the of the vortex of
Truth do you know what I'm saying all
y'all live in the on the sour cream go
ahead go
ahead all you live on the cheese and the
sour cream venture to the guac sometimes
sometimes you may you may venture to the
guac your boy lives in the
beans in the beans level of the vortex
of Truth so when you come to this
podcast be prepared to dig past the
guacamole get your diving suit on get
your sour cream diving suit on we here
we
go the reason why Reese's Peanut Butter
Cups taste good is because the Earth
needs us to get cancer he said
it I mean dude why are people not
understanding what I'm saying they are
they are the babies
are see this is why I say it's a cult
cuz the people who understand it we ride
dude we ride we ride and I tell you what
we do we ride on our enemies
too just like too PK did
man we ride on the enemies but anyway
Christmas was nice dude speaking of
rappers Kanye uh actually first before
the even Kanye thing he apologized final
by the the latest apology ever you
know eh mine took about nine months but
um him going to be amused am I
venturing into the
fashion did you see this C
nice are you venturing into the fashion
industry and is uh K going to be amused
am I venturing into the
fashion did you see this cat
yep that's a great coat
dude uh that's an old video but
he is he made an apology dude
for saying all the Jew
stuff and he wrote it
in
um Hebrew he wrote
in that's pretty wild he did
that or somebody just wrote cap you know
translated it means I sincerely
apologize to the Jewish Community for
any unintended Outburst caused by I mean
unintended he did it 150 times you know
it was a Jewish doctor that's my
favorite one
um caused by my words or actions it was
not my intention to offend or demean
respected and I deeply regret any pain I
may have caused I am committed to
starting with myself and learning from
this experience to ensure greater
sensitivity and understanding in the
future you forgiven your forgiveness is
important to me and I am committed to
making amends and promoting Unity you
know what's funny is like if you take
the flip side of this think about like
you know promoting obviously
anti-semitic uh rhetoric it yeah okay
it's obviously like just no hate just
you know don't don't
imagine the guy who took what Kanye said
to the next level in this instance you
know what I'm talking about like that's
the most
Darkly silly like to be like you know
what you know what dude I actually I was
fine with Jews to to be
like I was fine with Jews up until Kanye
you know he's making a lot of sense like
the fact that people are upset at him
for and but then you're like okay well
everyone in the Third Reich was
absolutely mentally unstable so you know
it's like okay you don't have to be not
crazy to make a difference that's the
truth in that God he [__] is in the
beans
again I'm sorry I'm in the beans I I
might just sit sit in the beans this
whole episode episode
but but dude you don't have to be not
crazy to make a difference godamn it
he's in a beans oh [__] theia is in the
beans again what's the what's the uh how
many what's in seven layer seven layer
how but dude I bet there's eight layer
dip seven layer dip what is in it what's
in it here we go here we go oh
[__] do you count olives as a hey do you
count olives as a topping is it a
topping or is it a layer if it's just a
topping okay but if it's not it's eight
layers and he's in the beans even
further
okay
oh oh [__] sour cream he's way past the
sour cream he's way I'll tell you what
if they put a dollop of cream cheese in
there he's past that he's he's past his
dude it's spread over the salsa forget
it he went dude you should have seen how
fast he went past the salsa and the
tomato and the bell pepper green onions
and lettuce over the top oh God did they
put cheddar cheese in it is a garnishing
black olives he in a
means
um so yeah dude you don't have to be not
crazy to make a difference sometime
people think like you know uh what do
you call it uh perseverance you got to
have that to a crazy degree not really
though if you just go at a steady pace
and you keep moving this is why you know
you keep this is why the tortoise won
steady Pace keep moving you'll get there
dude you'll get
there look at Rick Glassman everyone
thought he was crazy and his podcast is
amazing
um but he's not crazy well he's crazy
but um he's a crazy person but but we
love him we love him all the same he's a
good friend and we love him
um so yeah so oh wait let's look it was
a Jewish doctor let's see if we can find
that that should be on YouTube right
what would it be Kanye Jewish I'm just
going to say Jewish doctor Kanye Jewish
doctor we've already talked about this
but it's so funny
though wow oh here it
is Kanye West his anti-semitic
anti-jewish Ty
no you got
it doctor that diagnosed
me you got would you put on the thing
okay here we go here it is you always
find the clips Ivan all right here we go
how do you find these so quick
okay here we
go the thing about the red hat that
drove me to a point of exhaustion which
was
misdiagnosed by a I'm not going to say
what race what people uh doctor and what
hospital and what media went to we know
I can't say
that it was a Jewish
doctor dud the music
afterwards
dude that is some David Brent [__] for
real it was a Jewish doctor
um I mean dude couldn't help himself
anyway um that was my favorite that's
probably my favorite cone clip dude that
new [__] Kanye song that they didn't
clear yet because it's got the back stre
boys thing on it holy [__] it's so good
until he says pink and the stink it's so
good until he says and then he says
Burger King you're the King Burger King
but dude that's so so bad but before
that oh my god when they go
everybody yeah yeezy's back tonight dude
that's so ill God I got to get good at
singing Del's back all right dude I
should have had that on my [__]
special
dude
um yo Kobe
Bryant that's Mamba campaign Kobe Bryant
um is start the Nike is still doing the
Mamba shoes with Kobe
Bryant
um they're doing the new campaign let me
tell you something man I don't know if
it's cuz I'm an old head or
what but KOB Ry shoes just I have one
pair and they're just not that good man
I hate I hate to say it because you
know but God dude the the [__]
Jordans and Yeezy you know but these
[__] Grinch sneakers that they're
talking about with the the Kanye with
the just
bad the Black
Mamba they're just I I can't
imagine putting these on but whatever
ever how about uh I watched
um Hunger
Games
uh the new
one and I go like this look I'm a Hunger
Games fan okay I like the franchise it
might be one of my top franchises like I
don't give a [__] dude right I'm not
holier than now I get when I say
sometimes I say uh hey you know uh I
really like the Hunger Games franchise
sometimes people go what that's the name
you're gonna bring up and I go yeah it's
good first of all Jennifer Lawrence is
topnotch she's so good at
acting uh and it's action-packed it's
dystopian it takes place in the future
it's like what else do you want Donald
southerland's in it it's like he you
know he's he's one of those guys that's
in movies right now where you watch and
you're like he's still alive I'm like
what do you what do you want you know
God how much is Donald suan someone that
would die on
Christmas but like shakes Shakespeare
did that uh I swear to God that's next
year Christmas Donald S and croaking out
um so you have there's a guy who die on
Christmas um he died already but not on
Christmas but
um
so when if you Happ to die Oh I thought
you looking
um so I'm watching Hunger Games and I go
like this I see them so here's the thing
always make the prequel don't even [__]
with sequels all right Hunger Games made
some nice sequels there wasn't like The
Scorch Trials or whatever the [__] that
thing was remember that one with uh the
Dylan
guy what is it Maze Runner that was good
the first one and then it was like what
are you doing after that yo hunter games
figured it out all right
I'm telling you they figured it out and
then I go but but here's the thing
here's the thing if you make a dope
movie make the prequel way more
interesting to see how the people that
you loved watching got there than it is
to see more different people after the
other people already died we don't care
God he's in the [__]
beans but when I make too much sense
that's where I
am hey look look up look up it's
guacamole
so I'm I'm I'm watching The Hunger Games
the prequel now so they did three movies
bang up job dude all right yeah the
first one was the best second one was
fine third one was fine and I'm telling
you if the third one's fine you did it
all right look at
Matrix Matrix one one of the best movies
of all time Matrix 2 is in the top 6
billion
movies Matrix 3 is in the top 25 billion
movies and then the new Matrix is the
worst movie you've ever seen right
behind Wonder Woman
1984 and Christmas Bloody Christmas
which is about a killer robot Santa that
I tried to watch the other
night
but
dude I turn on Hunger
Games whatever the [__] the new one is
called the the the the bird in the hen
or whatever the hell you know it's
probably something like that song Birds
versus snakes and snakes
whatever first of all intirely too much
singing in the [__] new Hunger I like
what's happening hey is it a musical
hey
dude okay so the lead is a singer fine
two songs hey is this hey are you in the
Jets is this Westside Story hey what the
[__] is this
Hamilton two song limit all right it's
like Jesus Christ she spent so much time
singing and I'm like here's the thing I
turn on the the the Hun Hunger Games I
would I call it the hunter games I meant
the Hunger
Games I turn it on the [__] I see the
lead actress and I go like this yo this
woman would I bet is so annoying right
she's like 20 or something you
know um and I'm sitting there and every
time she comes on the screen I'm like
man she must look like somebody that
like rubs me the wrong way or something
she she looks so
annoying then I go like this wait a
minute
is she the and I still don't know but
let me just make sure let me find out
right now Snow White
interview
controversy
no Rachel zler here we go is that her
yeah yeah Ray yep see I knew it it's
amazing what the [__] subconscious
will do I knew I saw in the middle of
movie I go like this I saw a clip of
this chick being [__] annoying dude
I my subconscious is the [__] dude so I
figured Snow White didn't she do the the
annoying here it
is here it
is let's get past the ads because I'm
never signed into [__] my YouTube
plus even though I have YouTube plus out
the anus dude but I'm never signed
in um a new modern age uh so Rachel Z
and galado on bringing a new Modern Edge
not age to Snow White stay when am I not
crying in public it's so upsetting why
were you crying oh my gosh I saw the the
well I didn't even we didn't even see
overwhel but I saw the logo and I went
that's my name Snow White's up there my
eyes out that's sweet what was it like
seeing yourself for the first time in
full Snow White DRFT all a snake that
guy full descrition no I dress here this
is the part I think what I know in what
I'm used to I think this is it CU this
the most replayed super super enjoyed
every so far I super enjoyed you said
you were bringing a Modern Edge to it oh
here go on stage what you mean by that I
mean this guy's voice he's like the lead
guy in that Chicago Fire show I just
mean that it's no longer
1937 and we absolutely wrote a snow
white that is she's not going to be
saved by the prince she's not going to
be saved by The Prince and she's not
going to be dreaming about true love
she's dreaming about becoming the leader
she knows she can be and the leader that
her late father told her that she could
be if was Fearless all right so it's
still about doing what you can to make a
a dude happy only happens to be your dad
and
dads is run dude whoa whoa we don't know
dude we don't know and I tell you what
man I don't know you know this it's fine
you know it it wasn't as bad as I
remember it it's fine she's probably a
sweetheart but man I remember and I'm
watching Hunger Games and I go what the
[__] and then I say to Kristen I say is
this the [__] chick that's playing
Snow White and she goes oh I think it
might be and I said that's why I think
that my subconscious came through
dude I love when my subconscious comes
through man thank you subconscious
you're very welcome me thank you me um
anyway she sang Too Much in the got a
great voice she's talented no no doubt
but got a great voice but sings there
too much singing and um I'm watching The
Hunger Games and I'm like this is going
to suck because the first three were
good you know you just how many times
can you make it
good
bro an hour into the movie I
go well I'll be
damned I'll be damned Hunger
Games you [__] did it again didn't
you not loud
enough
um let me do it again wow Hunger Games
you did it again didn't
you whoops and hit the DJ khed one don't
even know how
to okay you get
it those keys are too close together but
it's all good um all right uh Make It
Stop well it's all good I think it I
think it stopped now um we don't need
three of them oh it's oh there we go
okay
uh there's no way it's going to bomb
anyway I watch the hour in I go all
right I go all
right then my buddy buddy I say buddy
because we correspond online burn G I
don't want to mess up his last name I
say buddy like a
[__] Burn Gorman showed up I love the
dude great actor uh and he's in Hunger
Games and he kills it and dude he does
that acting where it's like oh want to
do it so bad where you just are kind of
screaming a little bit but more you're
more controlled but you still mean what
you say but you've obviously got a
backstory that maybe the actor created I
don't know if burn did that himself but
he was just
like feeling it you know he's good what
can you what can you say he's
good
um I watched Gran Torino or was that
Gran TMO the movie the video game movie
yeah
oh yeah gr Torino's the the other one
the what's his name Clint
Eastwood where he says [__] Asian
slurs all the time in the movie it's
just an excuse dude it's so weird to
write direct and star in a movie where
you just play a racist
guy you know it's like yeah yeah yeah
you
know you are racist though also if
you're 90 and white and you're racist
this just a has to be also everybody's
racist a little bit and it's okay it
doesn't mean I won't have black friends
doesn't mean I won't have Asian friends
but the second the [__] pops off where
the whites at it's all I'm saying dude
where the whites
at uh and not in a racist way in a we
don't really know you know
what I don't know never mind I take it
back
dude I I don't love I I I whites are all
right right whites kind of are annoying
sometimes man honestly whites are it's
they're such they're [__] you
know most woke people are white which is
like I hate
that
um like what's
this oh yeah
if you got to fight okay this
guy I mean so B this is bwa Eagle
form if whatever this guy
is if the whole world got into a fight
this guy would come in
sixth I mean this is the
the wow dude this guy will be in sixth
place in the whole world fight it' be
this guy and then like you know he'd die
the fifth place would kill him right
tonight I worked on some of the eagle
bwa form also known as the bwa Hawk form
it is a fire element in China dude
anytime they start talking about the
elements and [__] and fighting it's like
you don't really it's not a
thing bwa you know made it
up
Bro you've had implants in your cheeks
oh God you've had a dimple made in your
chin you've had your lips enlarged
you've had your ey eyelids reconstructed
eyelid reconstructed stupid on none of
it's
true none of it's true it's BS they made
it up they lie they don't want to give
me credit for anything one paper said I
had each cuz I was growing a little
beard he had each little hair
transplanted into his face with a laser
lasered in how ignorant is that I
mean yo he looked crazy I'm actually I
haven't looked at Michael Jackson in I
mean a long time like really looked at
him this is
wild I can't even grow a beard now oh
this is this is from the South Park [__]
we like no you're ignorant come on
please is you're ignorant you ignorant
fool who wrote Such a you've had
implants in your cheeks oh God this is
like why don't they [__] press the
Rock on steroids you know like this is
how I I think about this [__] had a
dimple made in your chin you've had your
lips enlarged you've had your ey eyelids
reconstructed eyelids he said he was so
nervous stupid none of true none of it's
true he just grew up like that true it's
BS they made it up he looks I think he
looks amazing honestly keep listen to me
now
bro I'm sorry I'm going to say it
beatboxing is [__] so stupid
dude it's so gargantuan
stupid am I alone on
this beatboxing is just like you're
alone
you don't have love a [__] when I see
somebody good at beatboxing I go like
this
a a when you see someone beatboxing go
like this real loud
a they're
just
it's it's just beyond dude
and then there's stuff like and then
there's groups dude
hey
groups hey a
quadrant hey a quadrant of you guys just
outside at a mall
somewhere one of you guys is that guy
you
know when they do this kind of [__] you
know a quadrant of
[Music]
you okay that guy's actually not even
bxy
so like calling out Mayday calling out
Mayday okay all right I don't mean to be
racist but
[Music]
the
trumpet okay dude that's so dope
but yo you're so good for
real develop relationships
though look at
[Music]
me
nothing
what if the beatbox was so good that we
got copyright
[Music]
struck this is a contest
dude oh send it to
you it's oh right yeah I got to send it
to you
dude
[Music]
dude that guy did the
zipper that's four Dudes right
[Music]
there wow how did he do that but
a you know what I'm saying it's pretty
legit but don't do
it wait there it is
um I just can't really get on the the
fact that people are still doing it is
the craziest thing
dude it's not 1987
anymore they got real good at it pretty
soon though they're just going
to that Asian guy was so
dope that Asian guy was so dope here we
go I don't want to
[Music]
put call out
May
[Music]
oh I'm going to learn how to do this and
do it on [__] dates with my
wife dude baby I've been working on this
thing just I I want to I want to spark
the love back into our
relationship calling
[Music]
out just the waiter um would you would
you like more
bread sorry dude I was
beatboxing yeah Rick listen to me
now just [__]
[__] oh sweetie dude I I know sorry I
it's I thank you for coming and meeting
me at dinner I I know I just been
swamped man I did been doing my podcast
and all that stuff but anyway what do
you think you're going to want for
dinner and she starts answering and just
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding listen listen to me
now ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding dinging ding ding calling
out
Mayday just [__] with enchiladas in
front of
[Laughter]
me dude it's all good dude it's all good
it's all right all day all
night back when hip-hop used to just do
they still do that on the radio
all
day uh all day and all night or how
about the when they would do the um a
guess who's back in the mother FR of
house with the fat C for your mother of
mouth if get SC this and Z do
too it's just and you're just oh oh okay
uh I'll just buy the CD back
then
are swe wordss they got to go away by
the way they're who cares
anymore you know I was listening to a
clip song the other day cuz my son has
key the the key cards they're just
credit cards or they're old like the Y
cards and whatever those sizes crck
cards and uh he says I got key cards dad
and he was bringing them around and then
I was like I there's a song I play that
song it goes Keys open doors Keys open
doors Keys open Keys open Keys open
doors by the by clips and he wanted to
listen to it all the time and Calvin was
like they're saying bad wordss and it
was so cute I was like ah it's just the
song don't worry about
it
[Music]
um
but Keys open doors oh this guy
ate this guy at
eating
eating eating eating so casually
[Music]
eating I I tell you what dude if I
[__] could dance like this I'd have
35 illegitimate
children like I yo I would be all I
needed if I would if I could dance like
this bro I would be dead I would be
so this guy's so dope I will I if I
could dance like that my life would be
so different and I mean it I would be in
Europe no [__] that I'd be in New Guinea
just living a life you would never I
would not be famous people would just be
it would be have you ever heard remember
that guy I was one of those guys
remember that guy that [__] he moved
to New really the guy who [__] would
dance who did the [__] yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he lives in New
Guinea now really uhhuh guess what what
he's the leader of a tribe
what yeah the guy the tall would look
like a bird
yeah really he's a leader of a tribe in
in in in New Guinea in
Tunisia God that I ate I
eat
um dude eight is so
stupid yo this is so funny people are
sending me this because are saying this
guy looks like he's related to me but
who is this guy and he is insane that's
my [__] problem and
yes I like to [__] and that's my [__]
problem other than that I've got no
[__] problems so I guess I'll spend
the rest of my life solving that final
one every day I mean gangster
slay my way
oh two cats and a win at
the this guy has never been invited to a
Thanksgiving dinner I I mean I am
telling you I'm this guy has never he is
this is a guy who because he has social
media now people know who he is in the
90s this dude would be homeless on the
streets unbelievable this guy's never
been invited to a thanks I like bad
[__] that's my my [__] problem and
yes I like to [__] and that's my [__]
problem other than that the way he's
talking about also like scratching is
and that's my [__] problem insane and
on the thing it says for my horny little
island girl h no [__] problems so I
guess I'll spend the rest of my life
solving that final
one every day the first one's bad but
the second one gangster
slay my way
oh the second one is killer bro the
second one is just like oh no what is he
doing he did not
eat he did not
eat he didn't
eat uh all
right uh that's wild I'll be in
Sacramento get your tickets Brea
California Phoenix Arizona El Paso uh
Albuquerque New Mexico Colona BC
Vancouver BC Rochester uh new York we
got a bunch of different dates go to
chris.com go to get the grow or die
merch right here and while you're out to
get the special chris.com
uh I appreciate you guys listening leave
a comment you know and uh subscribe
that's it for YouTube if you want to
catch the rest of the episode The Raw
the uncut the unedited version of uh
this episode all you got to do is go to
patreon.com christalia and you can get
the full episode and every other full
episode we ever do of congratulations
and also the extra episode we do a month
we've done this for now 2 3 years
there's a bunch of different uh episodes
that you can unlock immediately if you
get this now all for six bucks Chris or
patreon.com chr.com say patreon.com CHR
thank you very much
[Music]
congratulations